la renuncia de la diputada aida reina
wasabi deja al gobierno de nafta live
net como una coalición minoritaria en
concreto con 59 escaños frente a los 61
que reúne la oposición a corto plazo la
salida de la parlamentaria árabe del
partido de izquierda méretz supone para
el ejecutivo buscar más apoyos para sus
propuestas y negociar más algo que se
suma a la fragilidad de su coalición
surgida de una alianza de ocho partidos
que van de la izquierda a la extrema
derecha y que tiene una presencia árabe
inédita pero esto no implica un golpe
fatal para el gobierno israelí para que
eso pasara la oposición también dividida
debería votar en conjunto la disolución
de la que knesset con un nuevo llamado a
elecciones es decir que el bloque de
derecha y ultra religioso liderado por
el likud de benjamín netanyahu tendría
que unirse a la lista conjunta árabe y
el voto de reina hui suave y su voto por
ahora no apunta hacer caer el ejecutivo
en abril el parlamento israelí ya
presenció el abandono de la diputada
nacionalista y dit silman que había
dejado al gobierno y la posición en un
empate de 60 escaños mientras para
silman el gobierno no representaba
judíos y ccoo rina guys dijo no poder
apoyar más a una coalición que según sus
palabras fortalece su flanco de derecha
y acosa a los árabes de una forma tan
vergonzosa
múltiples desacuerdos se ejemplifican su
decisión pero la represión de las
fuerzas de israel en los funerales del
joven walid al sheriff y de la reportera
es irina bucle además de redadas y
disrupciones en la mezquita de al-aqsa
han sido la gota final así la
incertidumbre vuelva a dominar la
política israelí que deberá resolver su
estancamiento para evitar unos quintos
comicios en apenas tres años